[Musik]
der meeresspiegel steigt und wir werden
aktiv rufen sie in new york vor dem
hauptquartier der vereinten nationen in
ihrer mitte greta thunberg die junge
schwedin mit der im sommer 2008 zehn
alles begann
sie ist zum sprachrohr geworden redet
den mächtigen ins gewissen
sie ist die stimme einer globalen
jugendbewegung
der juli könnt ihr es wagen was tun wenn
mir habt meine träume gestohlen und
meine kindheit mit euren lehrern worten
jetzt ein wunderbar gehöre ich noch zu
den glücklichen menschen leiden menschen
sterben ganze ökosysteme kollabieren
wir stehen am anfang einer massen
auslöschung und bier redet nur über geld
erzählt märchen vom ewigen
wirtschaftwachstum wie könnt ihr es
wagen
klar und kompromisslos die botschaft von
greta thunberg die augen aller
zukünftigen generationen sind auf euch
gerichtet
wenn ihr euch entscheidet zu versagen
sage ich euch und wir werden euch nie
verzeihen
[Applaus]
not let you wir werden euch damit nicht
davonkommen lassen
genau hier genau jetzt ziehen wir einen
schlussstrich
die welt wacht auf und der wandel wird
kommen ob wir es mögen oder nicht
danke
angefangen hat alles in stockholm dort
treffen wir greta thunberg an einem
kalten freitagmorgen im februar kurz
nach acht ein paar mitstreiter sind
schon da vor dem parlament seit monaten
zieht sie das hierdurch schulstreik für
das klima ich denke ich bin zu jung um
aktiv zu werden
es ist absurd dass kinder diese dinge
machen müssen mitarbeiter sonst niemand
tut habe ich das gefühl dass hier tun zu
müssen
das ist meine moralische pflicht das zu
tun was ich kann
die usa setzten manche menschen sagen du
bist nur ein kind du hast keine
erfahrung menschen sollten nicht auf
dich hören aber die menschen müssen gar
nicht auf mich hören
solange sie den wissenschaftlern zu
hören auf die ich mich berufe ich
spreche auch nichts neues an was ich
sage sagen wissenschaftler seit
jahrzehnten
deshalb müssen die menschen nicht auf
mich hören so lange sie eben auf die
wissenschaftler hören
seit sie in der schule von den
auswirkungen des klimawandels gehört hat
lässt greta dieses thema nicht mehr los
sie will dass sich was ändert deshalb
kommt sie vor schwedische parlament um
die politik zum radikalen umdenken
aufzufordern
als ich das erste mal vom klimawandel
gehört habe war ich etwa acht jahre alt
ich habe davon in der schule erfahren
man hat mir erklärt dass der klimawandel
von menschen und ihrem verhalten
ausgelöst wird und ich dachte mir dass
das sehr merkwürdig ist denn eine so
existenzielle krise müsste doch das
thema nummer eins bei jedem sein und
dennoch wurde das thema von niemandem
angesprochen und wir haben uns auf
andere dinge konzentriert das habe ich
nicht verstanden
die menschen haben gesagt die klimakrise
ist sehr wichtig und wir müssen alles
tun was wir können um sie aufzuhalten
und trotzdem haben alle weiter gemacht
wie vorher deshalb habe ich damit
angefangen immer mehr über den
klimawandel zu lesen
und je mehr ich darüber gelesen hatte
desto mehr habe ich auch verstehen
können wenn du es einmal verstanden hast
kannst du diese erkenntnis nicht mehr
verdrängen oder übersehen und dann
erkennst du dass du etwas tun muss weil
so viel falsch läuft
es ist die entschlossenheit eines
mädchens die griether berühmt macht in
kattowitz auf der klimakonferenz hat sie
gesprochen das video ihrer rede hat sich
millionenfach verbreitet aber auch ein
entschlossenes handeln
das ist noch wichtiger als hoffnung wenn
wir anfangen zu handeln dann gibt es
über alle hoffnung
anstatt nach hoffnung sollten wir also
nach handeln schauen und dann nur dann
wird die hoffnung kommen beim
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos war sie
und hat den mächtigen ins gewissen
geredet
eine 16-jährige will die welt retten und
bekommt dafür in den sozialen medien
auch kräftig gegenwind
genau das hat gretas vater befürchtet
wir treffen ihn als er kurz vorbeikommt
um seiner tochter essen zu bringen
ansonsten hält er sich zurück das hier
sagt er ist gretas ding
meine frau und ich haben dass hierfür
eine sehr schlechte idee gehalten waren
höchst besorgt nicht zuletzt wegen der
sozialen klima wie die leute auf social
media reagieren würden
die idee hat uns nicht gefallen aber
greta hatte sich entschieden und sie
dachte das ist eine sehr gute idee
bei greta wurde vor einigen jahren
asberger diagnostiziert eine art von
autismus betroffene sind oft hoch
intelligent manche neigen dazu sich mit
themen obsessiv zu beschäftigen
[Musik]
ich denke wenn ich kein us pendant hätte
wäre all das hier nicht möglich gewesen
ich hätte einfach weiter so gelebt und
gedacht wie jeder andere auch
ich sehe die welt aus einer anderen
perspektive schwarz und weiß und ich mag
es nicht wenn menschen das eine sagen
und das andere machen und genau so läuft
es beim thema klimawandel
was wollen wir klimagerechtigkeit wann
wollen wir es jetzt rufen die schüler in
brüssel im februar
der gegensatz zu stopfen könnte nicht
größer sein
zehntausende sind das in belgien die auf
die straße gehen
ihre inspiration heißt greta wir machen
das alles hier ist der beginn der ganzen
bewegung bevor das alles begonnen hat
habe ich mich nicht um klimafragen das
gemacht zukunft auf dieser erde skypen
mit ihrem idol für die belgischen
organisatoren der klimademonstration ist
das was ganz besonderes
du bist ein richtiger held hier
nein ich möchte euch nur für das tanzen
was ihr tut es ist so wichtig dass ihr
das organisiert nein danke dir wir haben
dich in der zeitung gesehen
du hast mehr courage gezeigt als jeder
mächtige politiker dritter thunberg löst
etwas aus schon im februar kommen leute
die sie treffen wollen einflussreiche
leute sowie daniel ellsberg
friedensaktivist und whistleblower
während des vietnamkriegs
ich würde gerne sagen dass greta zeigt
wie eine person eine bewegung starten
kann
dass jeder das machen kann sie ist nicht
irgendjemand sie ist so besonders so
herausragend und nicht jeder kann ihrem
beispiel folgen
aber sie können stärke und inspiration
von mir bekommen und deshalb bin ich
heute hier
sie inspiriert mich und viele ihrer
generation
dafür wird sie später den alternativen
friedensnobelpreis erhalten
der chef der stiftung ist an diesem
streiktag ebenfalls vor ort
ingres als großes talent ist die
moralischen was sie sagt kinderleichten
moralischen konsequenzen die wir
eigentlich daraus ziehen müssen
die auf den punkt zu bringen also ich
mache es auch eine ganz klassische art
des protestes auf der straße sie setzt
sich hier auf einen öffentlichen platz
sie hat ihr schild dabei auf dem sie
diese wie sie sagt diese einfache
message wasser jeder machen müsste
deutlich macht und dann spricht sie mit
menschen die hier unterwegs sind in
jedem wetter wie sie sehen und das hat
sich halt ins wissen in den sozialen
medien verbreitet geht in vielen anderen
ländern weiter und auch die klassischen
medien kommen hierher und nehmen sie
waren das ist toll
warum wird gerät zum weltweiten phänomen
ein stochern treffen wir in maar entzog
er will mit seinem start-up lokale klima
initiativen weltweit vernetzen
er hat früh erkannt welche faszination
von dem entschlossenen mädchen aus geht
er war es auch der ton berg die
einladung nach kattowitz besorgt hat zum
ersten mal hat er sie an ihrem ersten
streiktag getroffen
sie hat mich berührt als ich in mein
büro kam hat mich dieser gedanke
beschäftigt ein einsames mädchen sitzt
da es fühlte sich an als ob sie die
einzige ist die versteht was passiert
und jeder andere macht weiter wie bisher
business as usual also habe ich darüber
auf facebook geschrieben bei eigentlich
wollte ich dass die leute hingehen und
sie unterstützen mit ihr sprechen weil
wir kein einsames mädchen mit dem klima
alleine lassen können
niemand anderen oder sich kümmert wir
müssen uns gemeinsam kümmern und ich
habe ihnen gesagt geht hin
ich glaube in einer stunde hatte ich
mehr als 10.000 likes es hat sich rasant
verbreitet weil es genau einen punkt
getroffen hat wie in dem märchen des
kaisers neue kleider
der kaiser ist nackt und genau das hat
greta der welt erzählt
damit hat sie auch polarisiert vor allem
im netz dort gab es von anfang an auch
kritik an thunberg teilweise sehr harte
kritik so gut darin zu leben was sie
predigt aber wenn du in einer modernen
gesellschaft lebst kannst du nicht 100
prozent nachhaltig leben das ist
unmöglich
mit crysis und wir werden die klimakrise
nicht damit lösen wenn wir glauben dass
die einzigen leute die darüber sprechen
nur solche sein können die leben wie
sonst niemand
dann wird niemand mehr darüber sprechen
unmöglich auf große bekommt die perfekt
android das natürlich können menschen
nicht perfekt sein
wir müssen versuchen besser zu werden
warum wir müssen überleben social media
als katalysator im positiven wie im
negativen
greta ist auf vielen plattformen aktiv
als sie auf ihrem twitter-account ein
foto von sich postete hagelte es kritik
zu viel plastik
also diese ganze müll den sie sich ja
auch politiker und aktivisten wie sie
überhaupt menschen die sich für wichtige
themen in die öffentlichkeit stellen in
den sozialen medien antun müssen dass es
unerträglich und da müssen auch die
sozialen medien was tun
zu dem thema wasser zum glück diskutiert
hat er mit ihr gesprochen hat es gibt ja
viele interviews inzwischen merkt gleich
dass sie sehr gut für sich selber
sprechen kann
das ist mit sicherheit nicht so dass sie
von irgendwie wenn es zum lokalisiert
hat sondern das ist eine junge frau die
sehr genau weiß was sie will und wofür
sie steht
auch caritas vater steht in der kritik
seine tochter sei von erwachsenen
gesteuert die familie schlager aus der
popularität profit er bestreitet das es
ist genau andersrum sieg pusht uns es
war ihre entscheidung von beginn an und
das arzberger ding darauf ist sie stolz
sie will die aufmerksamkeit darauf
lenken
sie glaubt das ist eine gabe ein über
den tellerrand schauen
es gibt ein paar die sagen sie arbeitet
für leute es gebe leute die mit ihr geld
machen
und das stimmt einfach nicht sie ist
komplett unabhängig sie entscheidet
alles selbst und das ist auch wichtig
sie wird von niemandem bezahlt ich werde
von niemandem bezahlt meine frau auch
nicht und so bleibt das auch in zukunft
warnte thunberg hat zwei töchter hofft
beide sei er stolz erzählt er uns an
gretas auftritt vor großem publikum
müsse er sich aber noch gewöhnen
als service ich bin nervös und ich sage
hier ganz klar du musst sicherstellen
dass die fakten stimmen
sie schreibt die reden selbst und dann
gucken wir drüber um sicherzustellen
dass jedes wort stimmt und wir bekommen
und wenn sie jetzt vor großem publikum
spricht hat die hilfe von zwei
wissenschaftlern in denen sie in kontakt
stehe
den kann sie ihre fragen schicken und
die helfen ihr dann auch mit den
richtigen formulierungen das ist das
einzige was ich ihr sage die verhärten
müssen stimmen
du kannst nichts falsches erzählt mit
jedem wort jedem auftritt jeder geste
steht seine tochter in der
öffentlichkeit vor allem den vorwurf
fremd gesteuert zu sein kann greta
thunberg nicht mehr hören diese vorwürfe
gibt es schon seitdem ich mit meinem
protest angefangen habe und ich glaube
dass die menschen das immer weiter
behaupten werden
ich sehe es egal wie oft man sich
erklärt sie werden weiter dinge über
mich erfinden und nochmals ich denke
dass ich zu jung dafür bin ich sollte
zur schule gehen wie es jeder andere in
meinem alter auch macht bei aber da
niemand sonst handelt denke ich dass ich
das tun
außerdem beschweren sich viele darüber
dass meine generation so faul und
politisch nicht interessiert ist
in politics aber sobald wir aktiv werden
sagen sie dass wir zu jung sind um das
ganze überhaupt zu verstehen millionen
auf der ganzen welt folgen mittlerweile
greta thunberg
die klimafrage ist ins zentrum gerückt
auch weil die jugendlichen druck machen
von der politik erwarten dass sich etwas
ändert
[Musik]
ob sydney oder new york greta thunberg
die kämpferin hat etwas ausgelöst
friday is for future ist zu einer festen
größe geworden laut und unerschrocken
erheben überall auf der welt junge leute
ihre stimme fürs klima
für greta thunberg hat sich sehr vieles
verändert als wir sie im august noch
einmal in stockholm treffen
sie kommt alleine so wie immer dabei
wird gleich das sturm über sie
hereinbrechen der us fernsehsenders cbs
wartet schon aufs exklusiv interview es
ist ihr letzter schulstreik in schweden
bevor sie sich auf die reise macht
richtung amerika es geht schlag auf
schlag im halbstundentakt fragen von in
und ausländischen journalisten grußworte
an mitstreiter in lateinamerika
[Musik]
ich heiße geräte tonwerk ich bin eine
schwedische klimaaktivisten meine
botschaft an euch ist
das ist ein globales problem
wir müssen das zusammen machen
zusammenhalten mittlerweile wird die
bekannteste klimaaktivisten der welt
abgeschirmt alles überwacht danke leute
jetzt ist essens pause mittagspause sie
braucht ein bisschen zeit für sich
dunkel
sie arbeiten für greta thunberg media
ehrenamtlich heißt es jeder interaktion
versucht ihr unterstützerkreis zu
steuern
auch gretas vater ist im hintergrund
wieder mit dabei
eine blume für greta es grenzt an
heldenverehrung was da an diesem freitag
in stockholm passiert menschen wollen
fotos mit ihr und es sind viele ihre
mitstreiter und das gemeinsame anliegen
gehen im greta halb fast unter wir
machen weiter wie immer aber die leute
werden sich vielleicht weniger dafür
interessieren was wir sagen und was wir
tun weil uns der promi der status für
euch
jeder kennt sie und das ist es was
promis aus macht die leute kennen sie
was ist inszenierung was ist echt klar
ist nur greta thunberg hat ein anliegen
und mitstreiter die ihr wichtig sind und
irgendwie geht es doch immer nur um sie
es fühlt sich sehr überwältigend an
es ist manchmal schwer damit umzugehen
es ist nicht meine bewegung
es ist die bewegung von uns allen
auch greta und malin aus zwickau wollen
ein foto mit thunberg zuhause engagieren
sie sich bei fridays for future
die schwedin hat auch sie inspiriert ja
ein foto mit ihr gemacht aber sie sind
hier so viele leute und sie war ein
bisschen genervt
das erwartet das ist sowas wie mit so
vielen leuten und dass sich das auf den
bildern sieht man sie immer alleine
stehen und mir war schon klar ist dass
sie nicht allein ist aber dass so viele
leute sind nach ich nicht gedacht
ja das dachte sich auch nicht hier sind
das so viele leute dir auch zu schauen
einfach bloß das dachte ich nicht dass
das so kraft er macht mit mal freude ist
future was war denn der impuls war das
kreta damit zu machen
auf jeden fall also dass sie einfach
dahin gesetzt hat und gesagt hat ich
habe mich in die schule wenn ihr nicht
handelt das war schon also allein hätte
ich das nicht getraut wenn sie das nicht
gemacht hätte hätte ich mich niemals
einfach so wurde also von wo die
politiker gesetz in split treffen wir
die publizistin jagoda marinic sie hat
ein buch geschrieben über moderne
heldinnen von ihr wollen wir wissen was
der erfolg mit einem teenager wie greta
macht
ich glaube dass jeder moment in dem man
in eine arena tritt und merkt man kann
fürsprache für etwas betreiben einen
menschen verändert und gerade einen so
jungen menschen mit greta tonwerk sie
ist ja 16 jahre alt es ist eine
verantwortung die für ihr alter mit
sicherheit ungewöhnlich ist und dieses
verantwortungsgefühl wird sie natürlich
verändern
aber ich finde nicht dass es sie zum
positiven oder negativen verändert wenn
man erlebt gleichzeitig wie sie diesem
wesenskern eigentlich von beginn an treu
bleibt sie hat einen bestimmten blick
auf die welt und diesen blick bleibt sie
sehr treu
greta thunberg spielt mit im konzert der
großen hat barack obama getroffen und
frankreichs präsident makro in rom war
sie bei papst franziskus dazu kamen
preise und auszeichnungen die goldene
kamera war nur eine von vielen
für die einen ist sie helden für die
anderen hassfigur
ihr besuch im hambacher forst hat zu
einem proteststurm geführt gerät zeigt
sich mit vermummten macht sich gemein
mit deren anliegen ist ok in manchen
fällen denke ich dass ziviler ungehorsam
gut ist und manchmal ist er einfach
notwendig wenn nichts anderes hilft
solange es friedlich bleibt uns niemand
verletzt wird nur friedlich liebt es ja
gerade nicht im hambacher forst wie naiv
darf eine 16-jährige klima ikone sein
jedes thema das wir öffentlich
verhandeln wir leben in einer pluralen
welt wird die menschen spalten links
rechts stehen die befürworter dort die
gegner
das heißt diesen druck muss sie sich
einerseits aussetzen
andererseits hat sie das besondere
merkmal eine junge frau zu sein und es
heißt neben den thematischen und den
sachfragen hat greta thunberg sehr
vieles auszuhalten was gegen sie als
person und als frau gerichtet wird
wir treffen noch einmal den unternehmer
ingmar entzog er hat greta vernetzt
stand aber auch in der kritik weil er
mit ihrem namen geworben hat als sie
schlagartig bekannt wurde weit über
schweden hinaus
ich glaube das gerät hat deutlich mehr
kritik bekommt darüber mit wem sie sich
sehen lässt als andere auch als andere
influenza und das hat damit zu tun dass
die klimafrage inzwischen den sehr
politisch aufgeladen ist
alle jungen menschen entwickeln und
verändern sich aber ich glaube im grunde
ist greta heute noch die gleiche person
nur hat sie jetzt deutlich mehr
selbstvertrauen und hoffentlich auch
mehr zuversicht dass die menschen ihr
auch wirklich zu hören
zum phänomen greta gehören mittlerweile
auch einflussreiche unterstützer die
sich um sie scharen wie auf ihrer reise
per schiff nach amerika ein pr event und
gesponsert das boot gehört einem
deutschen unternehmer zur crusat an
mitglied der monegassischen
fürstenfamilie
ich mache mir keine sorgen über
reaktionen
was mich beschäftigt ist ob wir etwas
tun oder nicht ob die leute die
politische macht haben reagieren und
handeln werden mit aller notwendigen
kraft mit thunberg ist ein
dokumentarfilmer an bord die marke greta
wird weiter ausgebaut
präsenter griff hat humberg ist desto
eher wird sie zu der schneise die zeit
meine ist die mächtigen ernst oder
spielen sie mit den bildern dieser
jugend und ich denke daher wird es für
greta turmberg immer gefährlicher auch
auf diesem weg weiterzugehen
eine reise die wellen schlägt
klimaneutral sollte sie seien an die
flüge der crew hatte keiner gedacht die
klimaaktivisten wird immer mehr zur
projektionsfläche
die einen hoffen auf ein klima wunder
die anderen auf ihr krachenden scheitern
ankunft in der neuen welt die un hat
begleitboote geschickt die die yacht mit
thunberg an bord in den hafen geleitet
auf ihren segeln die
nachhaltigkeitsziele der vereinten
nationen
der kampf gegen den klimawandel ist
eines davon
die klimakrise ist eine globale krise
die größte krise die die menschheit je
erlebt hat wenn wir nicht
zusammenarbeiten kooperieren
trotz all unserer unterschiede dann
werden wir scheitern
wir müssen zusammenstehen und uns
gegenseitig unterstützen und wir müssen
aktiv werden
sonst ist es irgendwann zu spät
lasst uns nicht länger warten lasst es
uns jetzt tun
schulstreik fuers klima.de schildpatt
thunberg mitgebracht nach amerika ein
neues publikum jubelt ihr zu
ihre botschaft wird auch hier gehört
geräte thunberg kämpft weiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]